j'attache beaucoup d'importance aux
accessoires vestimentaires certes par
exemple loin ce que j'ai fait est
revenue tant que tu as trouvé ta veste
jaune c'était quoi a même vu des brian
bartolomeo a joué le rôle du cube et je
fais si ce n'est pas maintenant je
cherche un travail qui était jugé
évident
c'est vraiment hésité comment un jour
par hasard mon choix c'est là tu vois
pas que le chapeau ça oui maintenant je
vous dis un peu largué comme ça après
ces cas-là du chapeau conseille au début
c'est que philips était magnifique a
écrit c'est que ya la possibilité du
recours si on regarde le film on voit
bien qu'ils pouvaient être utilisés
n'importe comment
et moi je me fais un 1 sur leurs proches
j'en suis là trois plans il ya trois
plans ou où je vais mal utilisé
mais je pouvais ne pas le mettre du tout
vous pouvez le mettre tout le temps
jaggi 30 à saint philippe
c'est qu'ils aient vous mais j'aurai mon
interview je vais vous montrer et mon
garde et ils vous donnent tous les
possibilités possible depuis subi les
louvanistes ailleurs qu'il faut bien
souvent su nous croyons pas non non non
ça va jusque là et alors la ppc fit un
grand chalet jeannot je vais te souviens
de mon petit partenaire qui ferait le
meilleur
je suis très partenaires ainsi que je
toucherai jamais eu jeudi les
partenaires fantastique prête il avait
signé un formidable il ya des
partenaires oui mais tu faisais
attention parce qu'on en dise est attiré
vers un journal ou un ami oscar de la
part du canadien fait partie
ça fait un peu plus grande rue
moi je m'en fous j'ai un grand film pour
gonfler ce décompte en fois bonjour j'ai
un grand film foot - affaire